what's the profile
of people who
uh
are child traffickers right what is the
profile what does this person look like
what is the profile for parents to know
what how do you know who's a pr you know
child predator how do you how do you you
really don't is the answer and that's
the frightening part of it we've had
guys surfacing our investigations are
doctors teachers
members of law enforcement
and yes there are characters who surface
who might as well have the word predator
tattooed across their forehead because
they look rangy they've had criminal
contact with the law before in this area
but i think and again i'm not a
therapist but in my experience these
guys break down into three different
categories there's the younger offender
right who 19 20 21
who finds a girl who's in her early
teens
says well
i have a hard time talking to girls in
person i'm going to do this online if it
works out great at some point she'll be
old enough and it won't be
illegal we've got the hardcore heavy
hitter on the other side of the spectrum
the guy who would be the little league
coach
you know the bad
boy scout leader the guy hanging out at
the food court at the mall this guy is a
stone cold pedophile predator can't fix
him and then you've got this group in
the middle
you know white-collar guys often who
have real jobs and real members of
society and oftentimes have families
they have a predilection towards wanting
to be with a younger boy or girl
but they wouldn't act upon it without
the internet the addictive nature the
anonymity and the 24 7 access and at
some point they get involved in these
conversations and they cross this line
between fantasy and reality and they end
up knocking on our door we had a guy in
our connecticut investigation
who was a real estate executive who i
had met on the commuter train
between connecticut and new york
and here he is showing up for a 13 year
old boy
in our investigation in fairfield
connecticut shocking so you don't know
what secret somebody may hold
you know in your everyday
moving around town in your casual
acquaintance it's a very interesting
thing you just pulled up tyler it says
profile of a predator their aim is to
gain your trust first before your child
think about that statement for a moment
your child is not the initial target you
are why because you are the gateway to
your child and your child's trust if the
adult gains your trust he has become a
trusted adult in your child's eyes and
this means your child will be much less
likely to disclose abuse by that person
thinking that you are will be angry with
them or will not believe that this
trusted adult would do such a thing the
information in this section will be
taken primarily from the book the
socially skilled child molesters
differentiate into kills
how is it that so many child molesters
get off uh get by with
what they do for decades without being
caught first of all please be aware that
they do very often get
by with what they do are doing because
getting comments like your children
so
interesting trusting your parent first
well that makes me think of larry nassar
or like a doctor jim exactly oh michigan
i mean you must know that story very i
do know it very well and it's it's
horrifying what what he got away with
and and how he got away with it for so
many years there's a doctor at michigan
who molested players
um
it is
it is up to
school administrators
to monitor this and in the nasa case at
michigan state there were warnings
and because
people in the athletic department were
more focused on football and basketball
they were not focused on this issue with
the gymnast but you know these brave
women
came forward
not pleasant
hurtful and told their stories and
that's what it finally took
for him to face justice but all what a
horrible human being
had been worn oh you could feel it
though in the court oh yeah you could
feel the darkness you could feel the
like
you know just the way he would stand
imagine how the parents feel yeah
uh being sometimes
on the other side of the screen didn't
one of the parents jump out or was that
a different case where
there was an incident yeah well one of
the fathers got upset
can you can you i don't relate to that
no i do i can't
yeah
there's other high profile stories like
obviously um what was the joe paterno
jerry sandusky
crazy situation i'm sure you have strong
jeffrey epstein epstein harvey weinstein
and then and even within politics
everything that happened with matt gates
a handful of months ago the guy out of
alabama roy moore yeah anthony weiner i
mean
it it crosses the landscape you're given
this profile but what about these
high-profile people the jeffrey
epstein's of the world i think
congressman yeah it's it's it's
a powerful
narcissistic
personality disorder
and they think that they can get away
with anything they want because they
have wealth and power and epstein's a
great example that because he was so
well politically connected in florida
and i'll tell you an interesting
backstory
a few years before it all exploded i had
a series of meetings here in florida
with
investigators and lawyers who were in
the case
and i actually tried to he had already
done his time down here and was out
and i tried to fashion a way to do a
sting
in new york with him and the levels of
security were such that it was virtually
impossible and at the time
victims were not speaking up about it
so honestly i got busy with other
stories it was the miami herald and
julie k brown who stayed on that story
every day
chipped away at it
convinced the victims to speak out the
survivors
and it's that kind of local reporting
that is so important and without the
miami heralds reporting on this
there may not have been criminal charges
uh and so you know i've got to give
you know a lot of credit to
her and the miami herald and other
people worked on the story there uh once
they indicted him obviously you know a
lot of people jumped in we're reporting
on it but it it speaks to the importance
of you really got to stay on a story
like that because it's it's hard to get
at somebody i mean look at how long it
took for the weinstein story
right he was working with women who
would wear two pairs of pantyhose
because
if he got
aggressive with them they'd have one
extra layer of protection imagine going
into a business meeting being a female
executive and thinking you had to wear
two pairs of pantyhose for your
protection
how shocking is that
what do you think's gonna happen what do
you mean two pair of pantyhose there was
a victim who wrote an op-ed piece in new
york times yeah about her experience
with harvey weinstein she was an
executive
and she would wear dress protectively
to give her extra time to extricate
herself if he became aggressive sexually
with her as he was known to do
extra undergarments extra undergarments
speaking of epstein and that just that i
mean the whole thing is horrible for so
many different reasons but when i read
that
for some reason it was just so shocking
that that that that anyone would have to
think that way
and that a guy like that could maintain
power in any industry for decades for
decades
speaking of epstein uh the you know
obviously i don't know if you have
strong feelings on who killed him or
anything like that but his partner in
crime literally was this uh jillaine
maxwell gallania galaine maxwell
uh
what's
we covered what happened with her and
her sentencing she's been convicted yeah
what are you like she's basically
an accomplice in what's going on there
what are your thoughts on that well i
think she was held accountable which is
good and proper i think the interesting
thing will now be
if she
you know gives a proffer to federal
investigators
to say here's what i can tell you
if you'll cut my sentence
and she's got a lot of time to think
about that now and she's not the kind of
person who's used to being in federal
prison although she deserves to be there
federal prosecutors will have to
make a decision
and what should we possibly do usually
like in the mafia if you give up the big
boss but the biz boss is dead big boss
is dead but how many other people were
enabling him how many other people
abused young women in this syndicate and
there are
a lot of powerful wealthy men allegedly
who were in this circle did they
actually act did they do something i
don't know didn't you go
into in deep like into
didn't you go to the island didn't you
go see his palm beach place you were
investigating a part of that weren't you
a part of it i didn't really go to the
island okay i mean he went to peter
nygard's place yeah peter nygard we were
intimately involved in that
investigation so peter nygard
is the fashion mogul
made genes for any number of private
label uh operations and for dillard's i
mean big big business
and he was based in canada but also in
new york and he had a big compound in
the bahamas at nygart very weird looking
thing go to his uh it's like jurassic
park jurassic park just google peter
nygard uh
bahamas compound yeah go to that click
on images you're not gonna believe this
guy's place
holy [ __ ]
yeah that doesn't even do it justice
like there's pyramids in there there is
structures in there it looks just like
jurassic park yeah i mean look at that
and what was going on here it's like a
playground for kids what was he doing
yeah so he was it turns out
that
nygard has a history of
sexual abuse and predatory behavior
going back some 50 years involving
thousands of victims not just models who
wanted to work for him
yeah he prides himself into looking like
a lion he's got he's a 78 year old guy
79 now and he's got this long hair and
he used to have these pamper parties and
he'd invite these women there
but he would
also sexually assault
young women
in the bahamas who would be lured to his
compound they would be drugged
violently sexually assaulted and many of
them were never taken seriously
we got involved in this
uh
a couple years ago and did a documentary
that's now on discovery plus called
unseemly the peter nygard investigation
and the reason this came to light was
his compound was next to
a billionaire
hedge fund
investor lewis bacon in the bahamas they
got into a beef over
property lines and environmental issues
and in the course of that legal battle
bacon's people and i'm sure you know who
he is
found all this information out gave it
to investigators
and
i knew some of these investigators and
we got involved in it the new york times
got involved in it the cbc up in canada
got involved in it and we
put this expose together but i was down
in the bahamas interviewing these
victims
right before covet great expose by the
way well thank you it was shocking
in its brutality
and so he's been arrested now
and he's in canada awaiting extradition
he's been indicted in new york
and they're looking at other members of
his circle is he done done
oh he's done okay he's going to die in
prison he's going to yeah he's not going
to trial yet they're still messing
around with the extradition but he tried
to get out on bond yeah private jet i
mean this is such a shocking case this
guy according to the allegations
would impregnate young women
this is crazy by the way have them brace
for impact yeah race for impact is right
have them
get abortions harvest the stem cells
from the aborted fetus and have them
injected
into his body as some form of of a
fountain of youth we these are the
freaking stories that the q anon talks
about this guy yeah yeah but this is
this is people are basically eating
babies this is real for this what is it
what is it this is something chrome
chrome yeah this is the guy
well i don't think q anon has any
insight into this case qnan has its own
thing separate of this but i can tell
you about the peter nygard case and in
the midst of this two-year investigation
we had
which resulted in the documentary on
discovery plus
you know it was doing this case was like
a 3d game of chess because we had to get
so many people to help and cooperate and
coordinate and and there was competition
and and you know to get down to the
bahamas and do these interviews and in
the course of this
i get a call from a guy i know who's
involved in human trafficking
investigations and says you're working
on the nygard case right i said yes you
are he goes i need you to talk to this
lawyer i know i said okay great well
turns out he's the lawyer for the
a guy who is a videographer for nygard
for two or three years
and had hundreds of hours of videotapes
on the private jet going to asia the
pamper parties and gave them to us
didn't even ask for money
and it was just well it was it was
amazing so imagine we were going to do
the story anyway holy crap but in the
final stretch
to get these videotapes
i mean it was it was it was in terms of
storytelling for television
man oh man
it was incredible did you watch this
yeah i watched it so what ends up
happening is
one of his uh
closest who he hires to be his assistant
a very attractive girl he hires him when
she was 17 she stayed with him for a
while
and
one day she's sitting there with the
people that are managing the property
husband and wife that was managing the
property and she writes like on a note
and she says i need help i have to
figure out a way to get out here some
message like that then
nygaard's the top helper in the house a
lady
who's seen a lot of this stuff taking
place
uh one day his sister her sister is
there with her with her and he noticed
nygaard taking her sister upstairs
and her sister's 13 years old says what
are you doing and he smiles gives a
smile to so that the day i saw that
smile i told myself to go to the beach
he says that's when i realized this is
if you're going to cry you're going to
do it to my sister
you know and i'm somebody so now you're
going to my 13 year old so we have a
problem here and the next thing all
these guys came together
and flipped and turned against them and
obviously the rest is history if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]
you